present in the opening scene we see a
group of gangsters tormenting a man who
seems to have failed to complete an
assigned task the leader of the gang who
looks like a creature threatens the
man's life just then another criminal
named Walter Locke also called payback
arrives and confronts the gangsters with
his dual pistols however one of the gang
members is protected by a bulletproof
jacket rendering the guns useless
payback then opts for hand-to-hand
combat utilizing his exceptional
fighting skills to defeat the entire
gang he even beats up the captured man
and ultimately kills him he thought he
was there to save him didn't you shortly
afterward the police arrive at the scene
and apprehend payback next the Global
News tells us about the devastated World
which has suffered greatly from wars
involving harmful nuclear weapons
millions of people have perished due to
nuclear radiation syndrome however some
have acquired superpowers these
superhumans have misused their powers
leading to riots and Chaos in entire
nation in response to this the US
government has established a high
secured super prison called sandhib to
incarcerate and manage superhumans it is
also revealed that payback holds a
personal grudge against superhumans
because his daughter died at the hands
of one of them over the past few years
he has been seeking Revenge by hunting
down super-powered people and has killed
more than 40 of them to date despite
being an ordinary person he is no less
than the superhumans currently payback
is sent to sandhib Super prison where he
can eliminate more superhumans just as
he desires in the prison he meets a guy
named Diego Diaz who possesses the
ability to share emotions and feel the
pain of others around him upon their
arrival a female officer named Morales
briefly explains the prison's rules the
prisoners there are fitted with ankle
cuffs that allow the officers to control
their superpowers what if their
superpower is in their arms both payback
and Diego are subjected to These Cuffs
before being sent to their respective
cells then day payback enters the prison
ground where he is approached by an
inmate named Diamond Jim it is revealed
that payback was responsible for the
death of Jim's bro who was also a
superhuman seeking Revenge Jim
challenges payback to a fight and the
latter promptly accepts the two then
engage in a brutal fist fight which
appears to be evenly matched
unfortunately before one of them can
gain the upper hand some officers arrive
at the scene and separate them both
Fighters are then taken to the infirmary
in order to mend up their wounds
meanwhile Diego is approached by an
inmate named Gordon Tweedy who gives him
a tour of the prison and explains some
of the rules he must follow Gordon
advises him to mind his own business
without interfering with anyone as they
wander around Diego asks if the lobe is
also present in San teb in response
Gordon warns him to lower his voice
before saying yes the lobe is believed
to be the most dangerous superhuman who
possesses an ability to manipulate
people's minds as a result of this he is
held in a special cell with his face
concealed by a mask and His Hands
restrained following this we were
introduced to the prison Warden named
Walton Devlin who is notorious for using
violence against the inmates driven by
Greed for wealth Walt names to extract
as much money as he can from his
prisoners before his retirement he
chooses the lobe for this task knowing
that the Superhuman can use his
mind-controlling abilities to get what
Walton desires despite offering the
lobe's special treatment in exchange for
transferring the money the lobe refuses
the deal which infuriates the warden
later on the deputy Warden becomes aware
of Walton's intentions so she expresses
her concern about exploiting the
prisoners for personal gain however
Walton tells her to keep her mouth shut
or else he will not refer her name to
the board stopping her promotion despite
her anger she finds herself powerless
against the warden's actions the scene
then cuts to the infirmary where a
doctor named Isabelle Josephs is tending
to the injured prisoners shortly after
Diego who has been assigned with the
cleaning Duty walks into the infirmary
there he engages in a brief conversation
with Dr Isabel who turns out to be a
Kind and Generous person compared to the
other prison officers later that day Dr
Isabella is assigned to conduct a
psychological session with the lobe but
their meeting is abruptly interrupted
when payback breaks into the room with
the intent to kill the lobe at first
payback knocks Dr Isabelle unconscious
and then proceeds towards the lobe
coincidentally Diego happens to pass by
at that very moment and notices the
commotion as a result he takes down
payback with a dive and manages to hold
him down until the prison officers
arrive Diego's action earns him the
respect of the Loeb who is considered
the most influential figure within the
prison with all the inmates respecting
him as a show of gratitude for saving
his life the Loeb summons Diego outside
his cell the next day he also offers
Diego the position of his assistant
acknowledging his courage however Diego
requests some time to consider the offer
from that moment onwards the loeb's
followers start treating the egg with
good care and respect later during lunch
break Diego shares a meal with a fellow
inmate named Gordon through their
conversation it is revealed that Gordon
was the very first prisoner in this
super prison for all these years Gordon
has been applying for parole but it has
been rejected each and every time
despite this he continues to hold on to
Hope praying that his next application
will be successful unfortunately when
the outcome remains unchanged and his
parole is denied again Gordon appears
visibly disheartened one day during
lunchtime one of the loeb's assistants
gives Gordon a metal object and the
latter uses it to unlock his ankle cuffs
he then climbs on the table rips off the
wire and recharges his body revealing
his superpower to control the
electricity following this he destroys
the prison's electrical system and even
kills one of the guards with his powers
this creates chaos within the entire
prison and all the superhumans start
fighting against each other but
fortunately before the situation worsens
the deputy Warden activates the backup
motor successfully restoring the
electrical system after this all the
prisoners are subjected to Electric
shocks via their ankle cuffs before
sending them back to their respective
cells meanwhile Gordon makes his way to
the infirmary where he gazes at a window
at the outside free world just then
officer Morales walks in the room and
Strikes him hard across the face upon
taking him down she reports the same to
the prison Warden who unexpectedly
orders her to kill him though initially
reluctant Morales complies with the
order delivering several powerful blows
to Gordon ultimately leading to his
death in the aftermath of these events
Walton suspects that the chaos may have
been part of the loeb's Escape Plan
seeking answers he approaches Diego
knowing that he has been in close
association with the lobe for the past
few days Walton takes Diego outside a
torture room and threatens him hoping to
extract any secret plans between him and
the lobe however Diego genuinely has no
knowledge of what is going on or why the
lobe offered him the position of his
assistant he just found me sexy finding
no useful information from Diego Walton
walks up to the lobe's cell and warns
him not to even think about escaping he
also points out that the best thing the
lobe can do is to work for him this time
the lobe changes his mind and agrees to
cooperate but he requests some time and
a device with a Wi-Fi network to
transfer money into his account
afterwards Diego who is still upset
about Gordon's death confronts the lobe
and asks him about his plan and what he
wants from him in response the lobe
cryptically tells him to wait until
Friday the day of the prison wardens
retirement on the other hand the deputy
Warden accompanied by two prison
officers heads down to the basement to
check on the electrical damage caused by
Gordon following this they call in
technicians to repair the damaged wires
the days pass by and the super prison
appears to have settled back into its
routine with only the lobe continuing
with his plans he uses a tablet provided
by the prison Warden and secretly
creates a virus for a jailbreak
elsewhere payback tattoos a cross sign
on his face
nice and sets out to confront Jim he
picks up a fight with Jim but for some
unknown reason the latter keeps ignoring
him finally the day of the warden's
retirement arrives Walton summons the
deputy Warden and Captain Jason into his
office to decide who will take on the
role unfortunately after a useless
speech he selects Captain Jason the
deputy Warden argues that she is the
most qualified and has served the super
prison for years implying that she is
the deserving one however Walton puts
the blame on the board members saying
that it was not his decision this leaves
the deputy Warden feeling devastated and
hopeless afterward Walton enters the
loeb's cell and hands him his tablet
instructing him to transfer the money
into his account unbeknownst to Walton
the lobe feigns to carry out the money
transfer but instead hacks into the
prison security system disabling all the
prisoners ankle cuffs this allows the
super powered prisoners to regain the
ability to use their powers and as a
result a large commotion Begins the
prisoners use their telekinesis instant
recovery teleportation laser intense
sound wave and various other abilities
to fight each other and also the prison
guards amidst the turmoil payback
continues his revenge mission to execute
the superhumans one by one it's amazing
that he doesn't get one-shotted
immediately a short while later Walton
is informed about the ongoing chaos and
decides to go out to investigate however
to his dismay the cell door is locked he
quickly contacts one of his officers and
instructs them to let him out the prison
officers on the other hand are
struggling to control the situation so
they turn to the deputy warden for help
the deputy Warden explains that the
entire system runs on a generator and
restarting it will reactivate the ankle
cuffs after learning this as if he
wouldn't have been taught that already
Captain Jason hurries to the basement to
restart the generator but before he can
do so he is confronted by Jim who is now
transformed into a demon-like form a
fierce battle in between the two and
despite the captain's determination
Jim's superhuman strength proves
dominant against him but fortunately
Captain Jason uses his wits and breaks a
large pipe which releases hot air and
ultimately scalds Jim to death he then
quickly rushes to the generator and
restarts it in the midst of all of this
Diego seeks refuge in the infirmary but
he is still able to hear the pain
experienced by other prisoners outside
causing him great distress thankfully Dr
Isabel Remains by his side doing her
best to comfort him in the lobes cell
Walton who is still unaware of the
load's true role as The Mastermind sits
calmly in front of him the lobe then
Reveals His deadliest secret power he
can possess the body of anyone he likes
exploiting this ability the lope takes
the warden's body as the host and knocks
the real Walton unconscious as the
system reactivates the deputy Warden
unlocks the lobes seldor the warden who
is now the lobe orders the prison
officers to lock Walton who is in the
loeb's body in the torture room he then
places the last order to release Diego
from the prison with the newly acquired
warden's body the lobe finally escapes
the prison venturing to start a new life
ahead and he will no longer be known as
hello subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching